[inaudible] just
a lot about best travel destinations. Where do I recommend people check out,
and this is a difficult question to answer but I'm going to give it a shot and
I'm going to name a few of my favorite spots that I have visited.
Number one would be assuming,
let's just say that you're in the u s but even not if you want to visit a spot
in the u s and there are many that are perhaps unique,
even odd in comparison to other places but very, very fun New Orleans,
I would highly recommend it is a combination of cultural culinary influences
that come from seemingly almost every corner of the world,
the national parks. So I would suggest people,
if they have not visited the national parks or perhaps they visited one or two
when they were younger, make a point of getting on the calendar at least one.
I think that Zion is incredible.
Yosemite certainly is just beyond belief and there are many, many others,
but you can take your pick outside the u s few options. If you are,
for instance,
interested in parking up for a period of time and the longer you stay in a
particular location outside of the u s the cheaper it will be.
Your primary expenses,
I think it's fair to say are going to be in shorter trips,
airfare and hotels. If you're staying in hotels,
you're going to be paying top dollar per night.
Argentina spent nine months in Argentina, uh, around 2004,
2005 after I plan to be there for four weeks. I really fell in love with it.
It is a large country.
It is a very long country and you can't find everything from tropical
rainforests like Eco Sioux falls and Brazil all the way down to incredible
glaciers and killer whales and penguins way, way south. If you go to say Sierra,
they wiggle and you are as close to Antarctica as you really possibly be without
being in Antarctica. Next up if you want to go remote,
if you're looking for a combination of safety and English,
I would recommend going to New Zealand.
And of course there are many different options for English speaking places that
are fun. Uh, but go to the South Island of New Zealand,
get a car and drive your way down to Queenstown. Uh,
which is the adventure sport capital of New Zealand.
It's where they filmed a lot of lord of the rings where you find the remarkables
a mountain range and you can do such crazy,
insane stuff as a boogie boarding and rapids, which I tried and quite frankly,
it was more one of the more terrifying experiences I've ever had.
There's a lot of that. So if you'd like ATVs, adventure sports,
it's incredible and it's very, very beautiful.
It looks quite a lot like certain parts of Switzerland.
It's just stunning and people are very, very friendly.
If you want to get a feel for what New Zealanders are,
like at least some of them you can watch flight of the Conchords. Alright,
let's look at a very, very safe. And of course bad things can happen. Okay.
And they do, but very,
very safe generally and non English super alien environment.
What is the best combination of feeling completely lost,
bewildered in a foreign alien environment and safety that I've experienced has
to be Japan.
And I spent a year in Japan is my first time really out of s as an exchange
student going to a Japanese school in Tokyo, which was huge culture shock.
Living with a Japanese family and a Tokyo is just so awesome and so weird that
it's hard to find words to express exactly what it is like. And there's no need.
You should go, uh, it is not going to be cheap.
You can do it at moderate expense though. And uh,
it can be the trip of a lifetime. Then I would say, uh,
and this depends obviously person to person,
but take a trip to where some of your ancestors are from to be like,
oh, this is where part of my bloodline comes from. Make an effort.
So if you are, let's just say Korean American, you've never been to Korea,
go to Korea. So I would recommend like go somewhere where, uh,
if you trace your bloodline back, you actually have some, uh,
some genetic origins there. That's, that's also a really cool trip.
You can make a real impact on you.